I mean used to I wanted to be number one
and I would get a little jealous of
other people that were really successful
uh but the best thing in my life has
been really realizing it's the human
Continuum and that we're all basically
on the same journey together and other
people's success against tyranny is My
Success so I'm the happiest I've ever
been uh and uh and I just all the
persecution's been wonderful uh it's
really taught me a lot and uh and it's
helped me be a better person so I I want
to thank my enemies for everything
they've done to me and I want to
encourage them not to be destroyed by
their master that will destroy them and
I want to have a future with them on a
planet we can all live on and so I want
to tell my enemies I love you and I care
about you and Jesus loves you and you
just need to ask Jesus to come into your
heart and God will set you on the right
path and forgive you and that's really
the answer and I would just really
encourage them to find God because let
me tell you God and the devil are real
you better get that straight